The particular flavor of machine
learning that we're going to focus on in
the first part of this course is
called supervised regression learning.
Those are a few big words.
Let's break it down word by word.
We'll start in the middle
here with regression.
Regression is a weird word.
I don't think whoever chose it to
represent what it means did a good job,
but we're stuck with it.
All that regression means is we're
trying to make a numerical approximation
or a numerical prediction.
That's as opposed to
classification learning
where we might be trying
to classify an object
into one of several types as opposed
to making a numerical prediction.
Supervised means that we
show the machine the x and
also, if you will, the correct answer y.
In fact, we show the machine many,
many examples of x and y, and that's how
it learns, okay, when I see this x,
this is the y that's associated with it.
That's the supervised component.
Finally, when we say learning, what
we mean is we are training with data.
In this class we're taking
historical stock data and
training the system to make a prediction
about the future, usually about price.
There are a lot of algorithms
that solve this problem and
are supervised regression
learning techniques.
You've probably heard of
linear regression and used it.
Linear regression is a method that
finds parameters for a model.
So we call it parametric learning.
K nearest neighbor, or KNN,
is an extremely popular approach.
And in fact, you're going to build
a KNN learner as part of this class.
What's different between parametric
learning and instance based, which KNN
is an example of, is that in parametric
learning we take the data, munge it
around to come up with a few parameters,
and then throw the data away.
In k nearest neighbor we keep all
of this historic data, the x and
y pairs, and when it's time to make
a prediction we consult that data.
That's what makes it instance based.
Anyways, we'll spend a lot of time
talking about k nearest neighbor.
Two other techniques that are really
popular are decision trees and
decision forests.
As you might guess, the way decision
trees work is they store a tree
structure and when a query comes in,
it essentially bounces down that tree
according to factors of the data.
Each node in the tree represents
essentially a question,
is this x value greater than or
less than this other value?
And eventually we reach a leaf and that
is the regression value that's returned.
Decision forests are simply lots and
lots of decision trees
taken together, and you query each
one to get an overall result.
So this is the definition of
supervised regression learning,
which we're going to use a lot, and
these are various algorithms
that solve that problem.